على كل حال سالنا الناس ما رايك بالسفر
خارج المواسم بعيدا عن الازدحام وفي اوقات
الدراسه والعمل نتابع
[موسيقى]
حقيقه يعني شيء جميل
ولكن في وقت واحد يسافر بها ويرجع عشان
يغير جو حلو جدا للي ما عندهم اطفال ما
عندهم التزامات لكن للناس اللي عنده
مرتبطات زينه عندهم اطفال ما عندهم حل
لانه مسافره وقتلوا الاسعار بتكون مره مره
غاليه بس هذا الحل يعني اذا كان الانسان
[موسيقى]
متزوجات العائله يعني لازم نكون الاولاد
عندهم مدارس رح يكون موجود
الدراسه مثلا
المواسم وكده هي احلى في الاجازات طبعا
والله السفر من متع الحياه كل مكان
الانسان مرتاح اكثر بدون زحمه
الاسعار تكون مثلا اقل او تناسبه بيكون
مرتاحه اكثر
اكيد الناس بتسافر باستمرار يعني لكن كثره
السفر
ولكن كل انسان حسب رايه وبعض العالم يعني
تخرجوا عيالك وقت المواسم والبعض لا يفضل
الدراسه والله انا الناس اللي يفضل يعني
السفر بعد المواسم انه الزحام والزحام
والامور هذه اريح تقدر تاخذ راحتك يعني
تقدر تتمشى براحتك يعني وافضل يعني
[موسيقى]